I moved back to my neighborhood in the
late nineties,
after spending many years to try to
disassociate myself from it because it
was to me just the epicenter of urban
blight and you know,
it was dirty.
It does smell funny.
There were a lot of problems associated
with it.
And I'd also buy all my formative years
were kind of watching the disinvestment
of the community for both the financial
sector as well,
you know,
as business sector as well.
And it was a difficult place to be.
So when I got to school,
I got a chance to go away to school.
I left and I swore never to come back.
And it was only because I was so broke
that I had to move back home with my
parents.
And um,
but once I got there,
you know what got me there was the fact
that like there was this burgeoning art
community there.
So that was great.
And I was like,
I was an artist,
so I want it to be a part of that.
But what kept me there was honestly
getting politicized,
you know,
about recognizing that my poor community
was actually being targeted,
targeted as a place that for the
repository,
you know,
for all of the bad things that you
wealthier and usually wider communities
could avoid.
Um,
I came back home to find out that our
mayor Giuliani and Pataki,
our governor,
we're planning on building this huge
waste facility on our waterfront.
Um,
that would've brought about 40% of the
city's municipal waste to the area.
Even though we were already handling
about 40% of the city's commercial
waste,
it was an enormous amount of waste was
going to be,
again,
put upon our backs.
And so they were public health issues
associated with that.
And I just thought,
why is this happening?
You know,
I realized it was because it was a poor
community and a poor community of color
to the,
and the whole idea of environmental
justice is it just just simply means
that no community should have to bear
the brunt of lots of environmental
burdens and not enjoy environmental
benefits.
And right now,
race and class are great indicators as
to where you're gonna find good stuff
like parks and trees and really bad
stuff like waste facilities.
And it just really struck me as like,
I want it to be a part of the solution
and not just,
you know,
pretended it didn't exist or just,
yeah.